KNOWS EVERYTHING.
GREAT GUEST.
WELCOME TO HANNITY.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY, MEDIUM MOB
WANT TO IMPEACH OR DULY ELECTED
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
OVER WHAT IS A BIG, HUGE PILE OF
NOTHING.
THIS IS EVEN 1,001 TIMES WEAKER
THAN THE RUSSIA WITCH HUNT, THE
UKRAINIAN WITCH HUNT.
AFTER DAYS AND DAYS AND DAYS
NONSTOP PSYCHOTIC HYSTERIA, A
PHONE CALL BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE
PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE, CALLED BUT
NOBODY KNEW THE CONTENTS OF,
EVEN WITHOUT KNOWING THE
CONTENTS OF THE RAGING DEMOCRATS
ANNOUNCED IMPEACHMENT ANYWAY
WITH NO KNOWLEDGE.
STOP AND THINK ABOUT THIS FOR A
SECOND.
CLEARLY THEY WEREN'T GOING TO
MAKE THE MISTAKE OF ALLOWING A
SPECIAL COUNSEL LIKE MUELLER TO
DECIDE AGAIN AND DISAPPOINT THEM
AGAIN AFTER THREE YEARS.
NOT AFTER THE IMPEACHMENT
ANNOUNCEMENT, THE TRANSCRIPT HAS
ANNOUNCEMENT, THE TRANSCRIPT HAB
ANNOUNCEMENT, THE TRANSCRIPT HAE
ANNOUNCEMENT, THE TRANSCRIPT HAS
ANNOUNCEMENT, THE TRANSCRIPT HAD
ANNOUNCEMENT, THE TRANSCRIPT HA.
THIS IS AFTER WHAT THEY SAID HE
WOULD IMPEACHMENT OVER THEY
DIDN'T KNOW WHAT WAS IN IT.
NO QUID PRO QUO, NO DISCUSSION
OF USA, NO MISCONDUCT AT ALL
WHATSOEVER.
ZERO, ZIP, NADA, NOTHING.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS THE
SO-CALLED WHISTLE-BLOWERS OF
PARTISAN HACK WHOSE CLAIMS ARE
POLITICALLY MOTIVATED, TOTAL
B.S., WHO'S ACTUALLY REPRESENTED
BY A LAW FIRM THEY PUT UP LIKE
BILLBOARDS AND THEY PAY
OFFICIALS WHO LEAK DIRT, ILLEGAL
IN SOME CASES, AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP.
OR AS
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"'S
CURRENT KIMBERLEY STRASSEL PUT
IT, AND OTHER INTERNAL ATTEMPTED
TO GO TO PRESIDENT ON THE BASIS
OF ANOTHER NONSMOKING GUN.
THIS IS WHERE I GET SERIOUS.
WE HAVE IN THIS COUNTRY
DEEP STATE OPERATIVES ALIVE AND
WELL AND HERE IS HOW BAD THINGS
HAVE GOTTEN IN THIS COUNTRY
TODAY BECAUSE OF THIS ANTI-TRUMP
RAGE PSYCHOSIS.
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES CAN'T MAKE A PHONE
CALL TO A FOREIGN LEADER WITHOUT
GETTING SPIED ON AND STABBED IN
THE BACK BY UNELECTED
BUREAUCRATS, PEOPLE WEAPONIZING
THE POWERFUL TOOLS OF
INTELLIGENCE AND TURNING IT ON
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND TO THEIR
PRESIDENT.
YOU THINK ABOUT THIS.
OUR PRESIDENT IS TRYING TO LEAD
A GOVERNMENT ENTITY HAS PEOPLE
WITHIN HIS OWN GOVERNMENT THAT
ARE ACTIVELY WORKING AGAINST HIM
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
THE ONLY FAVOR PRESIDENT TRUMP
REQUESTED FROM HIS UKRAINIAN
COUNTERPART DURING THAT CALL WAS
AN INQUIRY INTO ELECTION HACKING
FROM 2016.
I THOUGHT THE MOB AND DEMOCRATS
CARED ABOUT THAT.
AND BY THE WAY THE UKRAINIAN
PRESIDENT, HE BROUGHT UP
RUDY GIULIANI IN THE COURSE OF
THE CONVERSATION AND AS FOR THE
BRIEF CONVERSATION ABOUT
JOE 30330 BIDEN, THE PRESIDENT
WAS RIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT HAS PROMISED THIS
COUNTRY SHOULD DRAIN THE SWAMP.
HE HAS A CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY, A
SWORN DUTY TO FIND OUT IF THE
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT OF THIS
COUNTRY ABUSED HIS OFFICE, YOUR
TAX DOLLARS, TO PROTECT HIS OWN
SON FROM POSSIBLE INDICTMENT AND
FINANCIAL GAIN.
NOTICE THAT THE SAME PEOPLE,
SAME CROWD THAT WERE WRONG WITH
THE CONSPIRACY IS IN LIVES AND
HOPES FOR NEARLY THREE YEARS
RAGING AGAINST THE PRESIDENT,
THEY'RE NEVER GOING TO SAY A
WORD ABOUT BIDEN.
WE HAVE ON TAPE HIM LEVERAGING
TAXPAYER MONEY TO FIRE THE
PROSECUTOR THAT HE KNOWS IS
INVESTIGATING HIS SON FOR
CORRUPTION AND WHEN THEY ARE
TIMES AND OTHERS GIVE HIM A
HEADS UP.
NOT A PEEP.
I'VE GOT TO BE HONEST.
I'M VERY HONEST TONIGHT AS I
ALWAYS AM.
I WORRY ABOUT THE FUTURE OF THIS
COUNTRY AND THIS REPUBLIC.
IT'S A REPUBLIC IF YOU CAN KEEP
IT, BUT BEN FRANKLIN SAID.
WONDER IF WE CAN KEEP IT UNDER
THESE CONDITIONS.
YOU WILL THE TRANSCRIPT THAT
THEY RELEASED, THE PRESIDENT
DIDN'T HAVE TO RELEASE IT.
YOU'RE GOING TO FIND THE UNION
PRESIDENT IS ALREADY FAMILIAR
WITH BIDEN AND HIS SON THEN THE
PROSECUTOR THAT WAS FIRED FOR NO
REASON EXCEPT TO GET RID OF
THE INVESTIGATION INTO A SON.
HE ALREADY BY THE WAY YOU PLAN
TO INVESTIGATE WITH A NEW
ATTORNEY GENERAL EQUIVALENT IN
THEIR COUNTRY BUT AS OF YET TO
BE CLEAR, ACCORDING TO THE DOJ,
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS NOT ASKED
OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR TO
INVESTIGATE BIDEN.
THE PRESIDENT WOULD NEVER ONCE
MENTIONED IT TO OUR ATTORNEY,
GENERAL BARR, NOR DID THE AG
EVER CONTACT THE COUNTRY OF
UKRAINE AND THE PRESIDENT OF
UKRAINE EMPHASIZED TODAY THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID NOTHING
WRONG.
HE GETS IT.
TOO BAD THE MOB IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND IS
OBSESSED, THEY CAN'T BEAT THEM
AT THE BALLOT BOX.
>> WE HAD I THINK GOOD PHONE
CALL.
IT WAS NORMAL.
WE SPOKE ABOUT MANY THINGS.
I THINK NOBODY PUSHED, PUSHED M
ME.
>> Sean: NOBODY.
ZERO MISCONDUCT FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP, ZERO CONFLICT
OF INTEREST AND ZERO ABUSE OF
POWER.
THAT DOESN'T MATTER IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT OF RAGE AND HATRED
AND REALLY A POWER GRAB.
THEY WANT THEIR POWER BACK SO
BAD AND THAT'S THE DEMOCRATS AND
THAT'S YOUR MEDIA, THE MOB.
THEY ARE BLINDED BY HATE AND
THEY ARE CRIPPLING THE ABILITY
OF A PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES TO FULFILL HIS
ENUMERATED POWER.
HE'S THE COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
WHAT FOREIGN LEADER HAS EVER
GOING TO WANT TO TALK FREELY TO
OUR PRESIDENT DOING HE'S BEING
SPIED ON?
THAT MEANS THEY ARE BEING SPIED
ON.
AND THE PRESIDENT HAS A SWORN
DUTY TO FAITHFULLY EXECUTE THE
LAWS OF THE UNITED STATES.
THAT IS GETTING TO THE TRUTH.
JOE BIDEN IS ON TAPE BRAGGING
ABOUT LAWBREAKING.
THAT DOESN'T SEEM TO CONCERN
ANYONE THAT HATES TRUMP.
INSTEAD THEY HAVE PUBLICLY
CALLED FOR TRUMPS IMPEACHMENT
EVEN BEFORE THEY KNEW WHAT WAS
IN IT.
THEY HAVE BEEN DOING THIS SINCE
2017.
THE FIRST MONTH THE PRESIDENT IS
AN OFFICE IN PELOSI'S
ANNOUNCEMENT YESTERDAY ABOUT AN
OFFICIAL IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY
MEANS NOTHING.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'VE BEEN DOING
THE WHOLE TIME ANYWAY.
THEY HAD BEEN CONDUCTING A NEVER
ENDING IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY SINCE
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
MELANIA TRUMP CAME DOWN THE
ESCALATOR IN TRUMP TOWER IN
2015.
WHAT WE ARE SEEN PLAYING OUT
OVER THE COURSE OF THREE YEARS
IS NOW A PARTY THAT HAS PUT --
PAY ATTENTION TO THIS.
THERE ARE RAGE, THEIR HATRED,
WHETHER THEY KNOW IT OR NOT,
THEY ARE NOT PUTTING THEIR
HATRED AHEAD OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
BUT MORE IMPORTANT ABOVE ALL
ELSE, ABOVE WHAT'S IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THIS COUNTRY.
THAT WOULD BE FOR PRESIDENT TO
BE ABLE TO FREELY CONDUCT
FOREIGN POLICY AS COMMANDER IN
CHIEF.
TODAY PRESIDENT TRUMP CALLED
THEM OUT FOR WHAT IS THEIR
DISGUSTING, DESTRUCTIVE PETULANT
MALICIOUS NEVER-ENDING BEHAVIOR.
GOOD FOR HIM.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> WITH THESE DEMOCRATS HAVE
DONE TO RUIN THE LIVES IS SO
SAD.
I'VE SEEN PEOPLE WITH ONLY GOOD
INTENTION.
THEY CAME TO WASHINGTON BECAUSE
THEY WANTED TO MAKE THE
UNITED STATES IN THE WORLD A
BETTER PLACE AND THEY WENT HOME
AND THEY WENT DARK.
WHEN USING WHAT HAPPENED WITH
THE VICIOUSNESS AND WHEN YOU SEE
LITTLE ADAM SCHIFF GO OUT AND
LIE IN AND STAND AT THE MIC,
SMART GUY BY THE WAY.
STAND AT THE MIC AND ACT LIKE
HE'S SO SERIOUS AND THEN HE GOES
INTO A ROOM WITH AND THEY MUST
LAUGH.
IT'S SO BAD FOR OUR COUNTRY.
>> Sean: BAD FOR OUR COUNTRY.
THE PRESIDENT'S RIGHT.
YOU'RE NOT GETTING A BILLION
DOLLARS.
I'M LEAVING IN SIX HOURS.
FIRE THAT PROSECUTOR.
YOU'RE NOT GETTING A BILLION
DOLLARS.
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GET IT.
THE GUY INVESTIGATING MY SON.
SON OF A B.
THEY FIRED HIM.
IT'S ALMONTE.
DEMOCRATS ARE FAKE AND PHONY,
IMPEACHMENT HYSTERIA.
IT HAS SERIOUS SIGNIFICANT
CONSEQUENCES FOR THE FUTURE OF
THE COUNTRY IF YOU'RE PAYING
ATTENTION.
WE'VE SEEN THE CONTENTS OF THE
PHONE CALLS LEAKED BETWEEN TRUMP
IN MEXICO AND PRESIDENT TRUMP IN
AUSTRALIA.
NOW PRESIDENT TRUMP IN UKRAINE.
YET TO DATE NO ONE IS EVEN
ASKING HOW THE SO-CALLED
WHISTLE-BLOWER'S CLAIMS WERE
LEAKED.
NO ONE.
THE POLITICAL AGENDA, HOW DID
THEY GET THIS INFORMATION, WHY
ARE WE SPYING ON THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES REPEATEDLY
WITH NO CONSEQUENCES?
NO PRESIDENT IN THE FUTURE IS
EVER GOING TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A
CANDID, HONEST CONVERSATION WITH
ANOTHER WORLD LEADER ON THE
PHONE.
THAT MAKES US LESS SAFE IN THE
END, DOESN'T IT?
THE TRUST HAS FOREVER BEEN
RUINED.
IT'S BEYOND A TERRIBLE
PRECEDENT.
IT HAS NATIONAL SECURITY
IMPLICATIONS FOR OUR KIDS AND
GRANDKIDS.
THE DEMOCRATS, IT'S THEIR
POLITICAL GAME.
LOOK AT THE HYPOCRISY
SURROUNDING THIS ONE VERY ISSUE.
DEMOCRATS CLAIM TRUMP SHOULD BE
IMPEACHED OVER SOME KIND OF
NONEXISTING QUID PRO QUO WHEN
THERE IS NO EQUATED AND NO PRO
AND NO QUO.
NO TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION.
IN REALITY, THE DNC, THE MOB,
THEIR FRIENDS, THE EXTENSION OF
THEIR PRESS OFFICE, THEY HAVE
BEEN SCOLDING THEMSELVES WITH
UKRAINE TO 2016.
WE HAVE REPORTED IT, AND
JOE BIDEN HAS OPENED THE DOOR TO
RE-EXAMINE IT ALL.
REMEMBER JOHN SOLOMON RIGHT HERE
ON THIS PROGRAM MARCH 2016.
CONTRACTOR FOR THE DEMOCRATIC
NATIONAL COMMITTEE WAS PRESSING
THE UKRAINIAN EMBASSY BECAUSE
THE DNC OPERATIVE WANTED TO FIND
RUSSIAN DIRT ON DONALD TRUMP.
THE SAME DNC CONTRACTOR ALSO
REQUESTED THAT UKRAINE'S
PRESIDENT PUBLICLY TRASH
PRESIDENT TRUMP THEN CAMPAIGN
MANAGER PAUL MANAFORT.
THAT'S NOT ALL.
EARLIER THIS MONTH IN A MEETING
WITH UKRAINE'S NEW PRESIDENT,
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR CHRIS       C
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR CHRIS       R
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR CHRIS       S
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR CHRIS       M
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR CHRIS       R
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR CHRIS       H
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR CHRIS       Y
REPORTEDLY THREATENED TO CUT OFF
U.S. AID.
THAT'S WHAT TRUMP DIDN'T DO THAT
THEY CLAIM HE DID AND HE DID IT.
IF THE COMPANY OPENED AN
INVESTIGATION INTO JOE BIDEN.
IN A LETTER FROM SENATORS
BOB MENENDEZ, DICK DURBIN,
PAT LEAHY, WE'VE GOT IT ALL
CHRONICLED, ALL THE EVIDENCE YOU
NEED.
DEMOCRATS THREATENING TO
WITHHOLD AID IF THE GOVERNMENT
OF UKRAINE STOPS INVESTIGATING
TRUMP-RUSSIA COLLUSION.
CAN YOU SAY.
QUID PRO QUO?
RUSSIAN COLLUSION, HILLARY, THE
BOOMERANG.
QUID PRO QUO, BIDEN, MENENDEZ,
LEAHY, DURBIN, CHRIS MURPHY.
>> IT GOT ALMOST NO ATTENTION
BUT IN MAY SEEN AND REPORTED
THAT SENATOR ROBERT MENENDEZ,
RICHARD DURBIN, AND PATRICK
LEAHY WROTE A LETTER TO YOU
KEYNES PROSECUTOR
GENERAL EXPRESSING CONCERN AT
THE CLOSING OF INVESTIGATIONS
THEY SAID WERE CRITICAL.
IN THE LATTER, THEY IMPLY THAT
THERE IS SUPPORT FOR U.S.
ASSISTANCE TO UKRAINE WAS AT
STAKE.
AND THAT IF THEY DIDN'T DO THE
RIGHT THING, THEY WOULDN'T GET
ANY ASSISTANCE.
GEE, DOESN'T THAT SOUND
FAMILIAR?
DOESN'T THAT SOUND FAMILIAR?
>> Sean: IT SURE DOES.
THEY ARE ALL GUILTY OF THAT
WHICH THE ACCUSED
PRESIDENT TRUMP OF.
HAD THIS CASE JUST LIKE IN THE
RUSSIA COLLUSION CASE, THE ONLY
ONE PAYING FOR RUSSIAN LIES
DISINFORMATION WITH HILLARY.
REMEMBER WHEN OBAMA, TELL
VLADIMIR ALL HAVE MORE
FLEXIBILITY AFTER THE ELECTION.
WE'VE GOT STATEMENT CASE YOU
FORGOT.
>> AFTER MY ELECTION, AND MORE
FLEXIBILITY.
>> Sean: I DON'T REMEMBER ONE
DEMOCRAT CALLING FOR THE
IMPEACHMENT OF "DON'T TELL THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE'LL DO IT AFTER THE ELECTION,"
THAT PROMISE.
DEMOCRATS REALLY CARE ABOUT
RUSSIA COLLUSION, WHERE WAS THE
OUTRAGE?
WE HAVE THE COWARDLY SCHIFF, THE
BIGGEST LIAR IN CONGRESS.
HE WAS TRYING TO ACQUIRE NAKED
PICTURES.
HE WAS BEING CRANKED.
RUSSIAN COLLUSION LOOKING FOR
DIRT ON AN OPPONENT AND WE GOT
THE TAPE.
LISTEN.
>> SHE MET WITH TRUMP AND SHE
BROUGHT HIM A RUSSIAN GIRL,
CELEBRITY.
ALSO KNOWN AS A PERSON WITH A
STRANGE REPUTATION.
>> HOW DO YOU SPELL HER NAME?
>> OLGA.
>> WHAT IS THE NATURE OF IT?
>> THERE WERE PICTURES OF NAKED
TRUMP.
>> PUTIN WAS MADE AWARE OF THE
COMPROMISING MATERIAL?
>> YES.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE WILL MOVE BACK WITH YOU TO
OBTAIN THESE MATERIALS AND I
APPRECIATE YOU REACHING OUT.
YOU AND I'VE GOT TO ADMIT, I
LOVE IT.
WHAT IS THE NATURE OF THE
COMPROMISE?
GIVE ME THE DIRT.
NAKED FIXATIVE TRUMP.
DID VLADIMIR SEE THEM?
OF COURSE.
IT GOES MUCH DEEPER THAN A MAN
ON TAPE COLLUSION WITH A
RUSSIAN.
THE COWARDLY SCHIFF.
HE'S BEEN LYING TO US FOR THREE
YEARS.
BIGGEST LIAR IN CONGRESS.
COWARDLY SCHIFF, COME ON THE
PROGRAM.
THE RADIO, ALL YOURS.
YOU AND ME.
DEMOCRATS, ARE YOU REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT ELECTION
INTERFERENCE?
WHERE'S HER FAKE PHONY OUTRAGE
ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON'S 30
RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
BUT "THE NEW YORK TIMES" SAID
LATE IN THE GAME WAS LIKELY
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION FROM THE
BEGINNING.
IF THEY CARED ABOUT OBSTRUCTION,
WHERE'S THE HYSTERIA OVER TO
35,000 EMAILS SUBPOENAED OR
DELETED, ACID WASHED, LITTLE
PHONES HIT WITH HAMMERED.
WHAT HAPPENED TO THAT?
IF THEY CARED ABOUT ALLEGATIONS
OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT AND ABUSE,
DEMANDING THE DEMOCRATIC -- WHY
ARE THEY DEMANDING THE
DEMOCRATIC TENANT GOVERNOR
RESIGNED FROM OFFICE?
WHERE ARE THE I BELIEVERS WITH
DEMOCRATIC PARTY AND BILL
CLINTON'S BEHAVIOR AND 18 OH
BRODERICK WHO BRAVELY CAME
FORWARD OR KATHLEEN WILLIE OR
PAULA JONES.
NO "I BELIEVE HER" THEN.
WE CAN'T FORGET ABOUT THE BIG
ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM WHICH IS
SLEEPY CREEPY CRAZY UNCLE JOE
WANTS TO BE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
IT'S NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
IF I MAKE A PREDICTION TONIGHT,
PAY CLOSE ATTENTION.
JOE BIDEN, JOE 30330 WILL GET
CRUSHED BY ELIZABETH WARREN IN
THE PRIMARY BECAUSE WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS ARE ABOUT TO DO IS
THROW HIM OVERBOARD BECAUSE THEY